hello and welcome to the shaky sign
shape where in this video we'll talk
about a new pathway for NAD+
biosynthesis so we'll touch a little bit
on metabolism a little bit by chemistry
and then also we'll talk about
supplements at increased levels of NAD+
so most of what I'll be talking about
today will be coming off the back of a
recent publication in nature metabolism
that shades this new pathway or at least
investigated how this precursor at our
age can be compared to delayed into NAD+
and it were fields that's one of the
critical enzymes involved in this
process is adenosine kinase now if that
just went over your heads we'll break it
down and gave her it step by step in
this video and explain what all of this
means and why it could be interesting so
before I explain NRH on adenosine kinase
we first need to explain NAD+ and why
you want to have high levels well you
could argue that nad plus is the most
important molecule in the body maybe
with the exception of ATP but without
either of them your dad's within 30
seconds I've mentioned was quite before
in this channel I'm saying
energy is a really important key factor
in the body and it's very abundant and
has a lot of functions in body but it
can be split down into two main
functions so this includes its role as a
redox coenzyme and secondly as a
substrate for nad dependent enzymes but
the problem is nad plus levels decline
as we age and so interestingly studies
are showing that by increasing these nad
plus levels actually extends the
lifespan in yeast worms and mice and it
protects against this age associated the
kind that we do see in nad which is also
associated with mitochondrial
dysfunction and physical performance
muscle loss of muscle regeneration and
kind of fission and other things you can
see listed there I say mechanisms to
increase nad plus level include
supplements such as and are an animal
which I've talked about previously in
other videos and in this video we're
speak about the link between animate and
improving fertility but in this video we
want to talk about an alternative to
these precursors and instead talk about
and our age otherwise known as by
hygienic
right beside so to get a broad
understanding of energy metabolism
because it is quite complicated first
I'm gonna just draw out a map or what we
know so far about NAD+ metabolism so
energy plus stands for nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide and in the cell
it's regularly regularly converted
between its oxidized form and NADH which
is its reduced form and so as I've
already mentioned T precursors and our
nicotinamide Rai besides and animal
nicotinamide
mononucleotide are upstream of NAD+
in addition energy plus can also be
salvaged from tryptophan in the cell and
so energy buses used up as I've already
mentioned in a variety of reactions
within the cell and that mainly is
regulated free sirtuins
and part enzymes and also in cd38 and
that leads to the product n a.m. or
nicotinamide and that can then be
converted back to Anam n which can then
regenerate NAD+ so these are the known
pathways but what we're going to talk
about in this video is an alternative
potentially parallel pathway to also
produce an eighty glass from NR h which
is actually the reduced form of
nicotinamide website and I say we'll
talk about how this happens and what's
the evidence that's been found enough
paper to support this and how could this
potentially be used in understanding
these assumptions so firstly what is NR
h so I already kind of mentioned it's by
hydro nucleotide right besides so it
actually is just the reduced form of an
R which he might have heard about as
being one of the main supplements for
increasing energy plus levels so what
she started to study in the first place
like why did they start looking into
this well what they found was when they
added an RH to mammalian cells they saw
a great increase in nad plus levels more
so than they've seen with adding
nicotinamide website so how is this
occurring so to understand the steps
that need to be taken to convert and our
H to nad plus you need to look at the
structure of these compounds because
that will give you a clue as to what
needs to be changed or modified to these
structures to convert one to the other
so I've drawn out here the structure of
NRH and also nad plus
say what we can see if we work backwards
is that to gain from NAD+ to NADH you
need to reduce that nitrogen I've
highlighted in yellow and then to get
from NIH to NADH you need to add
phosphate and also add a MP to the
structure to get an 88 and so if you're
struggling to understand this it's maybe
easier to understand it through the
parallel pathway which is converting
nicotinamide website to Enderman to an
80 plus you can see that it's pretty
much the same it's just the reduced form
in terms of NRA it's going to NADH that
is the main difference between ax t yeah
I said it's gonna get a bit complicated
but anyway the main point what they're
trying to do in this paper was to find
the protein that converts an RH and adds
phosphate to it to form an ax men aged
so the fancy biochemical name that we
give to proteins that have this activity
our kinase errs say so you identified
the specific kinase involved in this
reaction the autistic a proper
biochemistry approach and what that
basically means is you have your cells
and G extract the proteins from it and
then what you do is you can fractionate
these proteins based on their charge and
also their size and then you can do an
assay for each of these different
fractions to see which one has the the
activity that we're looking for in this
case the activity of converting air RH
into mmnh and so some of them have it
some of them date but it's the ones that
do have the activity that you can then
further examine and see exactly what
proteins are in that fraction and they
did that in this case and attempting
kinase was in the fraction and I
couldn't leave a lot of details but they
identified adenosine kinase in this
manner if you do want a little bit more
details just ask me in the comments and
I'll try and explain him a bit more
anyway she confirmed that adenosine
kinase is indeed the correct kinase
responsible for this reaction they then
took two approaches to test this so one
of them was to take themselves that had
well they're not expressing identity in
kinase the gene
been knocked out and say what you can
see in the graph is that by knocking out
demoscene kinase and adding an RH you
don't get that increase in nad plus
levels that you can see in the normal
cells and the alternative approach they
took was a pharmacological approach and
instead of knocking out adenosine kinase
they used inhibitor and that also you
have the effects of reducing the NAD+
levels that you can see if I went to k2
that with the pink highlighter so these
two preachers have both shown that
adenosine kinase is critical for getting
that increase in energy Plus levels when
an RH is applied to the cells so I feel
like a summary is needed at this point
to really explain why this is
interesting
and how does actually relates back to
the big picture that is nad + metabolism
so if we actually go back to the map
that I drew out to begin with and fill
in the knowledge that we now have
we know that NIH 3d activity of
adenosine kinase is converted to an MN
age and as already known in the
literature
mmnh can be converted to NADH and NADH
can be converted to nad class but the
interesting thing is that adenosine
kinase was already laying about and its
main asthmatic reaction is converting
adenosine into a MP and this is
interesting because a MP can be
converted to ATP adenosine triphosphate
which is the energy currency of the cell
as important for numerous reactions and
say these two compounds and RH and
adenosine actually competes with the
activity of the enzyme I'm sorry this
provides a further connection between
ATP metabolism and nad+ metabolism that
I brave critical for understanding
energy use within a cell so now we'll
move on to one of the implications for
nad plus supplements so as I said at the
beginning of this video a lot of people
take nmn and and are as supplements to
increase their energy Plus levels but
what's known as that NIH is actually
superior at increasing that the
concentration of nad plus so far based
on in vitro studies and there's actually
at
as a parallel pathway as we seen
compares and our nmn because it uses the
reduced ones so my question is could
they potentially be used in combination
such that you get an enhanced effect by
taking both and off and at our age and
supplement all words and our HR learn BS
superior method that is safer well the
fact is is that the moment reactions
don't know too much about our age as a
supplement because it hasn't really been
tested yet and so there's a lot of
understanding that we still need to have
about an RH before that's even
considered and fastly really we need to
work out what the impact is in this
competition move adenosine metabolism
and then secondly and apologies this may
cause further confusion there's a
potential link between methylation and
homocysteine levels that I've mentioned
before it's being a potential risk with
taking elemental and are as NAD+
precursors because one of the products
nicotinamide gets methylated and this
results in the production of
homocysteine and also actually results
in the production of adenosine and asked
me besides adenosine is the substrate
for adenosine kinase which is involved
in the NR 8 reaction but that's a little
bit of a sidetrack
ignore it completely if you don't
understand it and then suddenly we know
that I know it potentially could
increase levels of energy paths more say
than nicotine my website or animal but
it's really high level it's a good thing
you know too much of a good thing could
be a bad thing and then there's also the
understanding of the pharmacokinetics
and the solubility of
NRH and the feasibility of for even
being considered a supplement and then
just the icing on the cake I don't think
it's currently known how NIH even gets
into the cell so there's a lot of work
still to be done and to try and
understand the role of NIH but this
definitely does
adds a puzzle piece to the jigsaw that
is NAD+ metabolism so I think you've
learned something and I'm sorry if this
was just crazy complicated I do
apologize but anyway as always thanks
for listening